So then the first question was,
why are these Marxists
motivated by love or hatred?
Well,
is it love or hatred that produces
a hundred million dead people?
Is that enough evidence or not?
And if it's not enough evidence,
if you think to yourself,
well that's not enough evidence.
It was never really given its proper,
a proper try.
It's like,
well why would it be in proper try?
See,
I always think when I
hear someone say that,
I know what you think.
You think in your delusional arrogance,
did you understand the Marxist doctrines
better than anyone else ever has?
And that if you were the one
implementing those doctrines,
you would have ushered in the utopia.
That's what you mean when you say that.
And
no,
they say there's an idea in the
new testament that there's a sin.
It's a sin against the holy ghost.
If you commit that sand,
no one really knows what it is,
that you can't be forgiven.
And I would say,
well,
if you want a candidate for
the sin against the Holy
Ghost and the 21st century,
uh,
the statement
communism,
real communism,
was never tried with the underlying
idea that if you had been the person
implementing it would have worked.
I think that's a pretty good contender
for something for which you should never
be forgiven.
Yeah.
All right,
so that's Marxism.
So let's go on to postmodernism.
We talked a little bit about it.